c'est un peu noël avant l'heure sur
leurs traîneaux le père noël et le maire
de la ville ouvre le bal chars décorés
fanfare mascotte de dessins animés ou
encore acrobates ont transformé le
centre ville de poissy en une grande
fête féerique un succès qui fait du bien
même si les masques étaient également de
la partie les gens sont très heureux de
se retrouver la france a besoin de cela
et on le voit bien depuis le début de la
journée ici au village de noël c'est un
relais incessant de gens qui sourient et
on avait encore une fois perdu
l'habitude et moi ça me fait plaisir de
voir les pisciacaise et les pisciacais
sourire ce sont plus de 200 personnes la
plupart bénévoles qui ont défilé sous un
ciel clair un clin d'oeil cette année
pour la russie on est ici sur la place
rouge la place rouge qui qui inondent la
place de la république la place rouge
parce que la ville de poissy va être
jumelée avec une ville moscovite une
ville russe qui s'appelle kalouga et
donc on a décidé de faire un clin d'oeil
à nos amis russes comme on l'avait fait
que nos amis allemands là on est en
compagnie russe donc la tenue
traditionnelle
représentation la russie et on danse
je suis
[Musique]
on a dit
et tout le monde a joué le jeu quand on
peut finalement être dans l'habit de
lumière et dans l'habit du père noël
pour faire sourire les gens je me pose
pas de questions et je suis très heureux
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
pisciacais et les pisciacais s'en posent
pas également la parade de noël à roissy
elle est vraiment très connue est
phénoménal
un rendez vous qui comme chaque année a
su faire briller les yeux des habitants
en attendant les fêtes